Да, это шаг номер пять.
Оскар, можете мутить себя на Дискорд?
Да, правильно.
Следующий шаг – Реалтайм Транслава.
Вы должны создать автотранславу.
Да, язык, язык, язык, язык, язык, язык, язык, язык, русский.
Пожалуйста, открыть сеть и выбрать язык, язык, язык, язык.
Я слышу Оскар, сейчас.
Я вижу Оскар, он говорит: «Я могу видеть».
Наши слова были переводены из английского в русский язык.
И это было переводено довольно интересно.
Потому что сейчас я говорю русский.
Я не знаю.
В верхней стороне мы видим язык, что в верхней стороне есть, язык из которых это переводится.
Это написано в русском, это написано в английском.
Разные фразы попали в переводке, и в тексту вверх.
Это неизвестно, но это выглядит довольно понимаемо.
- Я согласен. - Здравствуйте.
Да, это переводится очень интересно,
Интересно, потому что это рассказывал русский язык с твоей голосом.
Я как-то удивляюсь, когда я слышал это, что я говорю русский язык.
Да, да, это интересно.
Но субтитры наоборот, немного странные.
Иногда я слышал, что не с твоей голосом, но с другими людьми,
с какой-то скромной фразой.
Но это интересно.
Также у нас есть большая длайка в транскрипте, я вижу, когда Оскар говорит, что текст и голос выйдут 5 секунд назад.
У меня есть странный момент, где это переводится на английский язык, я не знаю, что я могу найти в транскрипте, но это будет.
как я знаю, после этого, мы должны получить...
то что следующий степь?
я думаю...
следующий степь - "Субтитры и транспорт"
это part 6
мы можем включить "Subtitles" button
также нужно открыть "Transcription"
я возвращаюсь обратно к русски
мы проверим "Subtitles"
Субтитры сделал DimaTorzok
Не знаю, как проверить это, поэтому я думаю, что мы закончили с этой частью.
Это была часть номер 5 и 6.